[Music]
much of the nation has been riveted by
Gwyneth Paltrow's Civil Trial over a ski
crash now a verdict has been reached the
Oscar winner was in court yesterday when
a Utah jury announced their unanimous
decision that Paltrow was not liable in
a 2016 collision with another skier
during the eight-day trial haltro
maintained that she was the one who was
hit and you can see the relief on her
face when the jury agreed with her
what percent of the fault do you assign
to Terry Sanderson
100 percent Gwyneth Paltrow smiled at
her attorneys after the verdict was read
Terry Sanderson claimed to have suffered
life-changing injuries when he claimed
Paltrow collided with him on a beginner
slope of a Park City Resort what amount
fairly compensates Gwyneth Paltrow for
economic damages one dollar outro's one
dollar award made it clear the case for
her was not about the money in a
statement after the verdict the Oscar
winner wrote I felt that acquiescing to
a false claim compromised my Integrity I
am pleased with the outcome as Paltrow
left the courtroom she touched
sanderson's shoulder and had a few words
for her accuser her exact words I wish
you well very kind to her serious
serious smack never been hit that hard
and I'm fine for just over a week
Sanderson and his attorneys attempted to
paint Paltrow as a careless skier who
caused major injuries and left him to
suffer and nothing but the truth so help
you God but Paltrow said it was the
other way around repeating exactly what
she said to the retired optometrist
after the Collision seven years ago
you skied directly into my effing back
and he said oh sorry sorry I'm sorry the
arguably low stakes trial captivated pop
culture with its quirky moments you were
wearing goggles a helmet yes okay it
kind of looked like everybody else on
the slope that's always my intention
okay
probably had a better ski outfit though
I bet I still have the same one I just
have one Paltrow did not address the
media after court was adjourned but her
defense team spoke on her behalf Gwyneth
has a history of advocating for what she
believes in this situation was no
different and she will continue to stand
for what she believes is right
well so ends I thought it watched 2023.
well the next thing to watch is Saturday
Night Live they're gonna have a field
day this is a great week for Saturday
Night Live to actually be live yeah and
Quince as a host but I thought it was
very uh classy for her yes to say to him
on the way out considering all the
things that he had said about her in the
courtroom to say I wish you well 100 it
didn't take the jury long either no
because I mean you know I I don't I know
we were sort of laughing at her uh um Mr
sanderson's lawyer sort of seemingly
enamored with Gwyneth uh but she must
have known that she was in the right
because she agreed to come on into the
courtroom every single day to defend
herself but with a jury you never know
you're right about that never never know